we can get you anywhere you go the
government had been sending messengers
to women who ran away and leave the
country intimidating and harassing them
trying to get them back trying even to
get nothing
this is a constant fear of women who
flee from the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
Manal al-sharif is a women's rights
activist an engineer and author
manal fled Saudi Arabia and now lives in
a self-imposed exile in Australia and
she is here with me today
manal thank you so much for joining us
now since you fled Saudi Arabia how
different is your life now I've been
living in Australia for two years now so
yesterday it was my second University
and everyone asked me when they asked me
about my life I said if anyone asked me
about my age I am two years old this is
the time I finally living in a
self-imposed exile where there are no
societal constraints religious
concentrates no expectations you mean
yourself for the first time you just
look in the mirror you don't have to
meet anyone expectation to be who you
are just become your mind also some
before because they go back to Saudi
Arabia I would be very careful crafting
my message is self-censoring the things
I say now one can write and speak freely
because I'm not going back to Saudi
Arabia and I can openly criticize the
government and openly criticize the
political system in Saudi Arabia and ask
for reforms when did you decide okay
Saudi Arabia is not safe enough for me
I'm living a very long story it didn't
happen right away it took me eight years
to realize that I can't be inside Arabia
especially when I chose to accept
speaking speaking invitation to speak
about me I for the first time in public
and I went to Oslo in Oslo Freedom Forum
and I spoke about growing up as a
radical Muslim and how I had to online
all the radical ideas that I was brought
up believing in covering my face
believing infidels should do should be
killed because they're not
not they're our enemies so just growing
up with all these ideas and and then
challenging them as a woman on an
international stage like Oslo Freedom
Forum when I went back to Saudi Arabia
there was the way there was a fatwa that
I must act I'm not a Muslim anymore and
I was called also traitor the opinion
was so much and the death threats were
real when I was there after I came from
also in 2012 May 2012 and that's the
month I had to go I had to leave the
country I kept going back to Saudi
Arabia but I couldn't live there anymore
and did your father also have to give
you the permission to leave the country
in 2012 yes my father until this day I'm
training for this year and my father
until this day is the one who gives me
the permission to leave the country as a
adult woman a mother of two now before
moving on when exactly is the male
guardianship system and the Saudi law
all women must have a male guardian beat
a father a brother husband or even a son
now let's take a look at what exactly
they used for the woman would need
permission from a male guardian for the
most basic of needs education employment
or even to travel or marriage now
manal you are one of the pioneers of
your generation to demand for the dry
right to drive but you're not alone what
is the fate of your fellow women's
activists in Saudi Arabia so when a few
weeks before the ban is officially
lifted in Saudi Arabia and the woman who
fought all these years for the right to
drive been all summoned all of them in
solitary confinement today and those
women being tortured and these
allegations being confirmed by human
rights organizations and by their
families I confirmed it from their
families myself and those women are
today in jail and no one is really
talking about them no one is bringing
them
and finally they are sending them to
trials after nine months in jail and no
one knows what other charges they're
facing so this is a call to Germany and
today to PN Union to bring up such a
serious allegation of violation of those
women's rights activists and human
rights activism there's all details
today why they're in jail what are they
there
what are their child without charges
against them and why they don't have
access to legal help you have pointed
out a very important issue of the women
in Saudi Arabia but as a woman in exile
following the case of Khashoggi mother
what fears do you have living in
Australia knowing that you have a Saudi
Arabian embassy in Australia living
abroad after Jamal Kazuki it was a huge
shock for everyone I wrote for the same
industry in the Washington Post with
Jamal Hazuki and I used to write in the
same newspaper in Saudi Arabia with him
so twice we write for the same newspaper
and the Routan way of his assassination
and how the body was also disappeared no
one knows but his buddy it was sending a
very clear message that we can get you
anywhere you go the government had been
sending messengers to women who run away
and leave the country intimidating him
harassing and trying to get them back
trying to kidnap them and these are
allegations that I've been receiving
from women of an asylum on Exile there
are 18 woman 80 women applying for
asylum here xiety woman applying for
asylum here in Australia is epidemic the
the UN the UN refugee commission last
they said in 2018 2018 they've been
1,000 Saudi applying for asylum abroad
and this epidemic number shows you
exactly what's happening people are
leaving the country applying for asylum
in fear for their life
if someone is in Saudi Arabia and is
watching you right now what tips would
you give them if they are planning an
escape what would you have what would
you do if you were in their shoes if you
are in Saudi Arabia at this time do not
talk do not even breathe just be quiet
because it's really dangerous they're
putting their life in danger they're
putting the life of their families in
danger so it's not safe at this time
people like us on a self-imposed exile
we can bring up the media attention to
the abuses that's happening in Saudi
Arabia women who run away the only thing
I can tell them is you have they have to
be they have to have financial support
because when they run away it's really
difficult for women to get housing or
food or basic needs with them when they
don't knowwe there are two women about
they've been stranded in Hong Kong for
the last five months they were trying to
come to Australian apart for a song and
government revoked their visa when they
knew they were coming here and applying
for asylum I told them don't come to
Australia because the asylum the asylum
the asylum laws in Australia are really
brutal they stab you from your
credentials so you can't even use your
credentials to get a job you don't have
access to health care you didn't have
access to welfare you have access to
nothing here so I just say if you want
to run away from if you're in Saudi
Arabia stay quiet if you run away and
they didn't run to Australia it's one of
the worst countries trying to thank you
so much man al for your time it was a
pleasure having you here thank you I am
NOT free while any woman is on free even
when her shackles are very different
from my own these words from Audrey
Lorde and african-american civil rights
activists beautifully wrap up the story
of Manal al-sharif who even after
fleeing Saudi Arabia continues to fight
for the rights of women there that's all
from me today to make sure you don't
miss any videos like this one click on
the subscription button below and leave
us your comments as well until next time
goodbye
[Music]